burrito literally means little donkey it
is the sliced bread of food that is not
sliced bread where did the burrito begin
where any burrito begins with fit
tortilla tortillas originally made from
corn have been used by early
Mesoamericans from the Mayans to the
Aztecs they would fill their tortillas
with chili peppers tomatoes mushrooms
squash and avocado the influence of the
Spanish in the 1500s
gave birth to the flour tortilla the
perfect tortilla to create a burrito
but the burrito would not appear for
another 400 years the 19th century
Vaqueros of northern Mexico would fill
their tortillas with machaca dried
shredded beef frodo burritos the legend
of the named burrito comes from Ciudad
Juarez where one Mendes would deliver
tortilla wrapped meals on his little
donkey in the 1930s the burrito makes
its first appearance on a restaurant
menu in Los Angeles in the 1960s
burritos added to the English dictionary
around the same time as the first taco
bell it should also be noted during this
period that the world's most popular
rock band was formed and we successfully
embarked on the first manned mission to
the moon we're not saying burritos
created modern pop music and
interstellar travel we're also not not
saying that the 70s was the height of
burrito experimentation San Francisco
developed the mission burrito then there
was the San Diego marina meanwhile in
New Mexico the breakfast burrito in the
1980's Taco Bell invented the Kayseri
dough but it was too mind-blowing for
simpler times in the 90s with the
widespread popularity of grunge music
there were a few advancements chili
cheese burritos had some success but
they disappeared along with stonewash
Keens beanbag chairs blacklight posters
and tongue rings by the year 2000 the
quesadilla burrito medley was a sad
fantasy best leftist science fiction
conventions and KX theorists but that
didn't stop humanity from dreaming we
invented burrito vending machines Korean
BBQ inspired burritos and tiny burritos
fruit
and finally the world was ready for the
keys there you have it the evolution of
the burrito
you